and out of police in another state the
suspect in a workplace shooting outside
Chicago should have given up the gun he
used to kill five people the victims
include fathers of small children and a
college intern it was his first day on
the job Friday's shooting happened at a
manufacturing warehouse in Aurora
Illinois and Adriana Diaz is in front of
the Henry Pratt Company that's an Aurora
with what we know about the gunman
Adriana
good morning good morning the community
spent the weekend here holding vigils
for the victims and their families you
want to pray today more than 1500 people
attended a prayer vigil Sunday outside
the Henry Pratt Company their pain
filled the air diana hores his father
vicente was one of those killed another
victim plant manager Josh Pinkard sent a
heartbreaking text to his wife writing I
love you I've been shot at work in a
Facebook post Terre Pinkard wrote it
took me several times reading it for it
to hit me that it was for real police
say the suspect 45 year old Gary Martin
brought a 40 caliber handgun to work and
started shooting after he was fired
according to police Martin was an
illegal possession of a gun that he
first purchased legally
he had a 1995 felony conviction for
aggravated assault that did not come up
on his background check when he legally
bought the gun in March 2014 the
conviction did show up when Martin
applied for a concealed carry permit
just a few days later which requires
fingerprinting that prompted a letter
from Illinois State Police ordering
Martin to give up his gun to local law
enforcement is he's supposed to
volunteer the weapon or if he doesn't
show up with the weapon should someone
from State Police go to his house the
letter states that he needs to
voluntarily relinquish the weapon and
we're looking into whether we followed
up on what agencies followed up on that
the company is opening its doors this
morning for any employees who want to
come in to grieve together four of the
five employees who were shot had been
released from the hospital the last
officer is expected to be out soon well
there's a little bit of good news to
that story thank you very much are you
drowning I keep thinking about that
intern guys his first day on the job
you're just sitting in a meeting you
know stories very tough